puis en ukraine le chef de la diplomatie
ne formule je cite aucune objection à la
réponse américaine
on en parle un peu plus longuement avec
vous bruno daroux bonjour une orestie
d'être avec nous on a écouté donc il ya
quelques instants la déclaration de de
sergueï lavrov on l'aura bien compris
moscou est en train de souffler le chaud
et froid oui parce que en fait d'un côté
on l'a entendu moscou 10 que les
américains dans leur courrier n'ont pas
répondu à la principale revendication de
la russie qui est donc la fin de
l'élargissement de l'otan vers l'est et
notamment l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan qui pour moscou est une ligne
rouge donc ça de ce point de vue c'est
une très mauvaise réponse des américains
aux demandes russe mais par ailleurs la
russie estime que le dialogue peut se
poursuivre avec washington que les
américains font des propositions sur des
sujets qualifiées de secondaires par la
russie donc on va continuer à discuter
même si sur les points importants pour
chacun des deux camps il n'y a pour
l'instant pas d'avancé puisque les
occidentaux eux demandent qu moscou
retirer toutes ses troupes qui sont à la
frontière avec l'ukraine moscou refuse
et quant à la demande de moscou sur
l'otan c'est toujours un refus
catégorique de la part de washington
donc on voit qu'on est un peu dans dans
un plateau un pourrait-on dire en
référence voilà à la crise et un plateau
de l' escalade entre les deux camps et
on va sans doute rester comme ça pendant
deux à trois semaines pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que les troupes
massées à la frontière avec l'ukraine en
différents endroits par les russes sont
insuffisantes pour envisager une action
d'envergure en ukraine ça c'est un
premier point ensuite parce que les jeux
olympiques d'hiver à pékin alors vous
allez me dire quel est le rapport est
bien l'europe à vous le dit d'ailleurs
alors à penser qu'on attend des
médaillés et russe
les statines ses amis y aura puisque les
russes sont plutôt assez bon dans ces
jeux olympiques d'hiver donc il y aura
des médailles russe est donc l'opinion
publique sera satisfaite donc tous les
experts militaires notamment estiment
que s'il devait y avoir une forme
d'intervention russe en ukraine ce
serait autour du 15 au 20 février les
jeux olympiques se terminant le 20
février mais pas avant et pendant ce
temps là on va être très certainement
dans cette espèce de guerre diplomatique
froide entre les deux camps mais sans
finalement allé tellement plus haut ce
qui n'empêche pas dans le même temps les
européens bruno de de préparer de songer
à certaines sanctions les allemands et
français se sont même mis d'accord oui
oui absolument les les américains et les
européens
et explique que il se prépare comme ils
ne savent pas exactement ce que veut ou
ce que va faire vladimir poutine il se
prépare aux deux hypothèses une
hypothèse donc fortement axée sur la
diplomatie on continue à discuter on
continue ce que ma emmanuel macron appel
ce dialogue exigeant et nécessaire avec
la russie d'une part et d'autre part en
cas d'intervention on prépare à l'avance
en quelque sorte un paquet de sanctions
assez forte et sévère contre moscou
contre des oligarques proche de
l'entourage de vladimir poutine
peut-être même contre vladimir poutine
lui-même et puis il ya d'autres mesures
comme le fait que la russie soit exclu
du système des changes internationaux
swift ce qui serait très dur pour le
système bancaire russe et puis dans le
package des sanctions il ya le gazoduc
north stream 2 qui relie la russie à
l'allemagne alors ce gazoduc est terminé
pour l'instant il n'est pas encore en
service pour des raisons juridiques
plutôt côté allemand et il y avait une
hésitation faut quand même le dire
depuis quelques jours de la part du
gouvernement allemand qui constitue
d'une coalition aux intérêts parfois
divergents sociaux démocrates verts et
libéraux on ne savait pas trop si en cas
d'intervention russe en ukraine et bien
seraient brandies le fait de ne pas
mettre en service ce gazoduc north
stream 2 vient ce matin le gouvernement
le mans annonce que oui si la russie
intervient en ukraine et bien le gazoduc
north stream 2 ne sera pas mis en
service ce qui portera un coup dur quand
même à l'allemagne aux autres pays
européens qui sont très dépendants du
gaz russe mais qui en même temps fera un
gros manque à gagner aussi pour la
russie qui a besoin d'exporter son gaz
et d'en récolter des recettes merci
beaucoup